là on est dans la caponnière donc qui
était le point stratégique de la défense
de la batterie construit à la fin du 19e
siècle le fort de bois d'arcy était
destinée à renforcer le maillot ouest
des fortifications de paris il fut un
établissement militaire jusqu'en 1945
puis gérer ensuite par le ministère de
la culture
investi par le cnc le centre national du
cinéma et de l'image animée
il accueille officiellement depuis juin
1969 les archives françaises du film 5
hectares sont entièrement dédiées à la
conservation la restauration et la
valorisation du patrimoine
cinématographique français nous
conservons donc les films sur support de
sécurité c'est-à-dire fabriqués après
1953 et des bâtiments qui sont
contrôlées en termes de température et
d'hygrométrie pour assurer la pérennité
de la pellicule trois grands silos garde
précieusement une température d'un peu
plus de 12 degrés les supports plus
contemporains pour les supports plus
anciens sur nitrate de cellulose
étant donné leur caractère inflammable
ils sont répartis dans 236 cellule en
tout un peu plus d'un millions de
bobines de films sont conservés sur le
site de bois d'arcy ses mobiles en fait
n'appartiennent pas au cnc mais elles
appartiennent à des déposants qui nous
ont confié ces collections et que nous
conservons pour eux donc toutes ces
personnes qui ont déposé ces boîtes sont
tout à fait libres bien évidemment de
faire sortir temporairement pour des
projections pour des travaux en
laboratoire ou même définitivement s'il
le souhaite également
80 personnes travaillent ici incité de
travail qui n'a pas vocation à
accueillir le public en raison des
produits chimiques hautement
inflammables qu'il renferme
lorsqu'elle arrive au cnc la pellicule
n'est pas forcément en bon état et doit
passer par la case laboratoire elle est
ensuite scannées et numérisées
donc là c'est un film en noir et blanc
une fois arrivé à retrouver les nouveaux
le bon équilibre entre le noir et demain
une restauration qui peut prendre
quelques semaines pour un film de 10
minutes et jusqu'à plusieurs mois pour
certains films neuf mois ont par exemple
été nécessaires pour le film les
misérables d'henri fait secours de 1925
sa durée de 6 heures et tout aussi
exceptionnelle nous nous attachons à ce
que chacun de ses films
que ce soient des films réalisés par de
grands réalisateurs ou des films anonyme
soit conservé si vous voulez avec les
mêmes précautions pour permettre en fait
de transmettre l'ensemble de ce
patrimoine cinématographique aux
générations futures un trésor
inestimable bien garder au sein de ce
fort knox du septième art